classify quadrilateral ABCD choose the
option that best suits the quadrilateral
we're gonna pick whether it's a square
rhombus rectangle parallelogram
trapezoid none of the above and I'm
assuming we're gonna pick the most
specific one possible because obviously
all squares are rhombuses or rhombi i
guess it's a not all rhombi are squares
all squares are also rectangles all
squares rhombi and rectangles are
parallelogram so we want to be as
specific as possible in picking this so
let's see point a is at 1 comma 6 so 1
comma 6 I encourage you to pause this
video and actually try this on your own
before seeing how I do it but I'll just
proceed so that's point a right over
there
point a point B is that negative 5 comma
2 negative 5 comma 2 that's point B
Point C is that set some carbonated
water so some air is coming up Point C
is that negative 7 comma 8 negative 7
comma 8 so that is Point C right over
there and then finally Point D is at 2
comma 11 2 comma 11 and actually that
kind of goes off the screen this is 10
11 would be right like this so that
would be 2 comma 11 if we were extend
this this is 10 and this is 11 right up
here to calm 11 so let's see what this
quadrilateral looks like you have this
line right over here
this line right over there that line
right over there and then you have this
line you have this line like this like
this and then you have this like this so
right off the bat it's definitely a
quadrilateral I have 4 sides but the key
question are any of these sides parallel
to any of the other sides so just
looking at that side CB is clearly not
parallel to a is clearly not parallel to
a d there you just can look at it
now it also looks like CED is not
parallel to be a but maybe I just drew
it badly maybe they actually are
parallel so let's see if we can verify
that so the way to tell whether two
things are parallel is to actually
figure out their slopes so let's first
figure out the slope let's figure out
our slope of a B or B a so let's figure
out our slope here your slope is going
to be the change in the change in Y over
your change in X and in this case you
could think of it as we're starting at
the point negative 5 comma 2 and we're
ending at the point 1 comma 6 so what's
our change in Y our change in Y we go
from 2 we're going from 2 all the way to
6 or you could say it's 6 minus 2 our
change in Y is 4 what's our change in X
well we go from negative 5 negative 5 to
1 so we increased by 6 or another way of
thinking about it 1 minus negative 5
well that's going to be equal to 6 so
our slope here is 2/3 it's 2 over 3
every time we move 3 in the x-direction
we go up 2 in the y-direction move
through the x-direction go up 2 in the
y-direction now let's think about line
CD up here line CD line CD what is our
slope our change in Y over change in X
is going to be equal to let's see our
change in let's figure out our change in
X first our change in X we go from we're
going from negative 7 comma 8 all the
way to 2 comma 11 so our change in X
we're going from negative 7 to 2 or we
could say 2 minus negative 7 so we go we
are increasing by 9 that's our change in
X so that's going to be equal to 9 and
then our change in Y well it looks like
we've gone up we've gone from 8 to 11 so
we've gone up 3 or we could say
11 minus 8 notice endpoint - start point
end point - start point you have to do
that on both on the top and the bottom
otherwise you're not going to actually
be calculating your change in Y over
change in X but you notice our change
when we go to our x increases by 9r y
increased by 3 so the slope here is
equal to 1/3 so these actually have
different slopes so none of these lines
are parallel to each other so this isn't
even a parallelogram
this isn't even a trapezoid
parallelogram you have to have two pairs
of parallel sides trapezoid you have to
have one pair of parallel sides this
isn't the case for any of these or none
of these sides are parallel so we would
go we would go with none of the above